another day another record number of
arrivals at this Migrant Center on the
edge of the Darian jungle
exhausted men women and children get in
line to get registered by Panamanian
authorities
must have come from Venezuela Haiti or
Cuba others have traveled from as far
away as China and Sudan hoping to reach
the United States some can barely stand
after suffering injuries in their
treacherous Journey those with the forty
dollars for a bus ticket to the border
with Costa Rica get ready to leave
others like Angeline Castillo and her
sick five-year-old daughter are
pondering their next move she says they
were robbed in the jungle and barely
survived
we had to ask people for a piece of
crack of my little girl and a little
water as sometimes we ran out I felt
exhausted before reaching the first
canoe I had no more strength but I
prayed to be able to continue for my
children
for years a growing number of migrants
have been forced to pay criminal groups
to cross the Yen jungle between Colombia
and Panama nobody knows how many have
died trying
Panamanian authorities say their numbers
have more than doubled this year 70 000
people in August alone they expect to
reach 450
000 arrivals by the end of the year
a number that is overwhelming Panama's
capacity to process them and also
polluting the once pristine jungle with
we're confronting the biggest migration
phenomenon in the world and we're trying
to do it in the most responsible way but
we're also advising the rest of the
countries involved the origin Transit
countries like ours and the destination
to jointly share responsibilities
April the United States Panama and
Colombia agreed to try and crack down on
the smuggling rings that bring the
migrants Through the Jungle but Panama
says that due to a lack of information
sharing enough joint action on part of
Colombia nothing has happened
some migrants here say they didn't
understand how dangerous the Trek was
going to be and warn others
Asians Africans people from all over
please don't take this risk the fact
that some of us make it through unarmed
thank God it's not enough don't do it I
saw people getting shots everything in
the jungle can kill you but fleeing
conflict and the dream of a better life
remain irresistible for many migrants
ready to risk it all in a crisis that
continues to grow Alessandro Al Jazeera
Panama
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera